genau hier ist es passiert mit einer
faulen anmache lockt der afghane das
elfjährige mädchen in den neustrelitzer
schlosspark fällt dort kaltblütig über
sie her und vergewaltigt sie der täter
ist ein flüchtling aus afghanistan es
herrscht unklarheit über sein alter er
trägt keine ausweisdokumente bei sich
experten schätzen den jugendlichen auf
16 jahre der täter wurde wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs minderjähriger und der
vergewaltigung schuldig gesprochen
gerade mal ein jahr haft und auch die
nur auf bewährung es ist unfassbar und
genau darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
unserem bild chefreporter frank
schneider frank wie ist so etwas in
deutschland möglich
ja das hängt natürlich in dem fall mit
dem jugendlichen alter des täters
hauptsächlich zusammen wären wir gerade
gehört er wird zwar nur geschätzt das
macht das ganze natürlich zusätzlich
etwas eigenartig und auch wirklich etwas
unerträglich weil wir wissen ja gar
nicht ist er wirklich nur 16 ist er
wirklich noch jugendlicher und zum
anderen muss man sagen ein 16-jähriger
sollte auch schon wissen was er tut wir
diskutieren in deutschland permanent
über das wahlalter was reduziert werden
soll auf 16 und gleichzeitig werden ein
16-jähriger aber sehr behutsam behandelt
wenn sie so eine schwere straftat
begangen haben und das ist ihm ja auch
wohl ganz klar nachgewiesen worden ich
kann hier vielleicht mal zitieren aus
dem jugendstrafrecht und dann verstehen
wir vielleicht so ein bisschen woran es
liegt hier steht im mittelpunkt des
jugendstrafrechts steht der
erziehungsgedanke oberstes gebot im
jugendstrafrecht ist die erziehung und
das förderliche einwirkung auf den
jugendlichen täter ziel der
sanktionsmaßnahmen ist es dass der täter
künftig straffrei bleibt das heißt
dieses jugendstrafrecht konzentriert
sich wirklich nur auf den täter und ich
glaube da haben wir ein großes problem
denn wer denkt in diesem fall an das 11
jährige opfer der täter wird geschützt
natürlich auch nachvollziehbar ist jung
er hat noch ein langes leben vor sich
man will ihm noch mal eine chance geben
aber wenn er so eine schwerwiegende
straftat begeht es handelt sich hier
schließlich um ein verbrechen und dieses
elfjährige mädchen wird wahrscheinlich
ihr leben lang mit dieser tat leben sie
wird vielleicht später probleme haben
eine beziehung einzugehen sie wird
vielleicht ein gestörtes
vertrauensverhältnis insgesamt zu
männern haben sie wird vielleicht angst
verbindungen haben und das muss man auch
berücksichtigen und das ist beim
jugendstrafrecht häufig das problem man
schaut nur auf den täter man guckt nur
was hat der täter zu erwarten wie können
wir ihm mit praktisch helfen dass er
sein leben vernünftig weiterführen und
wenn man dann natürlich noch
berücksichtigen dass wir diese fälle
leider immer wieder erleben insbesondere
mit jungen zuwanderern es handelt sich
ja auch hier um einen unbegleitete
flüchtlinge dann ist das problem dass
sie häufig auch ein frauenbild nach
deutschland importieren was natürlich
mit unserem frauenbild überhaupt nichts
zu tun hat wir haben hier ganz klar
gleichberechtigung wir kämpfen für
rechte von frauen wir kämpfen hier auch
für rechte jetzt gerade im lgbt kyu
bereich und das muss man sagen das wird
häufig in muslimischen communitys
insbesondere jungen zuwanderern komplett
abgelehnt dieses dieser rechte die
akzeptieren sie überhaupt nicht junge
frauen die sozusagen mit ihnen mit gehen
leicht bekleidet sind betrachten sie als
freiwild und ich glaube dann ist so ein
urteil überhaupt nicht abschrecken und
genau darum muss es ja eigentlich beim
strafrecht auch gehen beim
erwachsenenstrafrecht geht es auch darum
beim jugendstrafrecht geht es um den
täter und nur darum dass es ihm
sozusagen trotzdem mit der tag ein
weiteres gutes leben möglich ist und da
habe ich halt großes bauchweh weil das
opfer und die handelt sich ich betone es
nochmal ein elfjähriges mädchen ein kind
was brutal vergewaltigt worden ist und
mit diesem dieser schrecklichen tat ein
leben lang leben muss anders denkt dann
keiner und das finde ich extrem
schwierig und ich habe auch große sorge
dass es in bestimmten communitys als
freifahrtschein betrachtet wird sein
urteil macht wirklich sprachlos vielen
dank für diese einordnung an bild
chefreporter frank schneider
der täter wurde wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs minderjähriger und der
vergewaltigung schuldig gesprochen
gerade mal ein jahr haft und die auch
noch auf bewährung unfassbar wie kann
sowas möglich sein genau darüber wollen
wir jetzt mit bild meinung chef philipp
potthoff sprechen bei uns im studio
halle philipp schön dass du da bist ja
wir wollen die frage gleich an dich
weiterleiten wie ist so etwas möglich
oder anders gefragt wie kann sowas
verhindert werden tja hier wird das
jugendstrafrecht angewandt der täter ist
ja 16 jahre alt zumindest geht man davon
aus dass er 16 jahre alt ist das heißt
erst noch nicht volljährig und deswegen
ist das eine bewährungsstrafe dh gilt
als verurteilter vergewaltiger
sprich er hat ein mädchen ein kleines
mädchen elf jahre alt vergewaltigt wird
rechtskräftig verurteilt und kommt
sofort frei weil es eine
bewährungsstrafe ist muss keinen
einzigen tag in haft bleiben das muss
man sich mal vorstellen kein mensch
begreift ja dass das eine strafe ist und
das ist ein zeichen an ihm und an seine
freunde und andere potenzielle nachahmer
man kann in deutschland ein kind
vergewaltigen und wenn man selbst noch
nicht volljährig ist dann bekommt man
eine bewährungsstrafe und bleibt
weiterhin in freiheit und können leben
wie man will was bedeutet das jetzt
genau für das opfer ich meine ein
elfjähriges mädchen wenn der täter
tatsächlich auf freiem fuß bleibt ich
glaube man kann sich gar nicht ausmalen
wie es dem mädchen und wie es auch den
eltern der familie gehen muss dass sie
wissen dass der junge mann der das getan
hat dass er
eigentlich nicht bestraft wird sondern
dass er weiterhin frei ist ein
unbeschwertes leben genießen kann und
dass er jederzeit wieder zuschlagen kann
natürlich bei ihr aber auch bei ganz
vielen anderen jungen mädchen wir kennen
solche fälle wo es nach einer ersten
vergewaltigung eine zweite gab und erst
dann hat die justiz wirklich
durchgegriffen und ein richtiger
haftstrafe ausgesprochen und man kann
natürlich nur hoffen dass es hier nicht
so weit kommt das jugendstrafrecht sieht
ja immer auch einen erzieherischen
charakter vor aber wie soll der aussehen
wenn der täter ja in diesem sinne gar
nicht bestraft wird was ist denn seine
strafe die er zu spüren bekommen sollte
ja ich glaube der erzieherischen
charakter dieser bestrafung oder dieses
urteils ist
dass man wirklich potentiellen
vergewaltiger sagt solange ihr
minderjährig seit oder zumindest als
minderjährig gesehen werden so lange
kommt ihr nicht ins gefängnis auch wenn
ihr ein kind vergewaltigt also man kann
dieses urteil keine menschen in
deutschland erklären unfassbar vielen
dank für diese einordnung philippi atos